okay y'all i am in the back of an uber
because we just got
breaking news okay
johnny depp amber heard the verdict
the verdict came out today so the jury
sided with dopp
and awards him 15 million
so johnny depp won his defamation case
against ex-wife amber hurd on wednesday
and the jury awarded him 15 million in
damages depp was awarded 10 million in
compensatory
compensatory damages and 5 million in
punitive damages in his defamation suit
the jury also awarded her 2 million in
compensat in in damages
the jury in fairfax virginia began
deliberating on friday depp sued herd
for 50 million after she wrote an op-ed
for the washington post in which she
called herself a public figure
representing domestic abuse heard
countersued debt for 100 million in the
statement depp celebrated his victory
in the his defamation lawsuit against
her so before i read the statement how
crazy is that that that washington post
gave her an op-ed with no proof
no proof
like as as a society why why do we just
believe women just because we're women
that's that's
if that isn't sexism i don't know what
is okay in in the state in the statement
depp celebrated his victory in a
defamation lawsuit against her six years
ago my life
my life the life of my children and the
lives of those closest to me and also
the lives
of the people who for many years have
supported me
were forever changed all in the blink of
an eye false very serious criminal
allegations were leveled at me via the
media which triggered an endless barrage
of hateful contacts although no charges
were ever brought against me it already
traveled around the world twice within a
nanosecond and it had a seismic impact
on my life and career
and six years later later the jury gave
me back my life i am truly humbled my
decision to pursue this case knowing
very well the height of the legal
hurdles that i would be facing and the
inevitable worldwide spectacle into my
life was only made after considerable
thought from the beginning the goal of
bringing this case was to reveal the
truth regardless of the outcome speaking
the truth was something that i owed to
my children and to those who have
remained steadfast in their support of
me
i feel at peace knowing that i have
finally accomplished that i am and have
been overwhelmed by the outpouring of
love and the colossal support and
kindness from those around the world i
hope that my quest to have the truth be
told will have helped others men or
women and who have found themselves in
my situation and that supporting them to
never give up i also have the position i
also hope that the position will now
return to innocent until proven guilty
both within the courts and in the media
i wish to acknowledge
the noble work of the jurors and the
jury
the court staff and the sheriffs who
have sacrificed their own time to get to
this point
and to my diligent unwavering legal team
as
has done an extraordinary job to help me
share the truth
so what does this mean about society i
think
looking back like when i go back to
thinking about five years ago um when
like the me too movement was super
prevalent it was like everywhere in the
media it was like left and right girls
were coming out with these me too
stories
i think as as women oftentimes our
natural ability to empathize with
women and with
just people in general makes us want to
believe victims
um and
while
i think that's naturally a good thing
in cases like this
when men are being abused they are not
believed because we automatically just
want to believe women
if five years ago instead of giving
amber heard an op-ed which is crazy that
a news publication would do this they
gave her an op-ed
for the i think it was vanity fair the
washington post one of the two
and if we waited for her to go to court
because if you were accusing someone of
abuse on a public platform you should be
willing to go to court why are you so
willing to go to the media before you go
to court
if you have evidence that it happened we
cannot keep giving people
and we cannot keep giving women
microphones just for the fact that they
are women like that it's not acceptable
as a society and i think if this
happened to one of the most powerful
like
one of the biggest actors in hollywood
how many average men has this happened
to
because that's what happens when you see
things happen to celebrity it shows
something that is going on in society
because if a man that has power and
money
this happened to you what's your average
joe supposed to do
and i think in the future
we need to be more critical of the media
too because
the the media needs to be held
accountable for this
um if i was johnny depp i would i would
sue the company that
released the op-ed while i was at it
like that's crazy
so
[Music]
i'm gonna see if there's any other news
from this so this is
this is insane um
i'm sorry i wanted to do a more put
together video but i'm literally on an
uber to go to europe
um
i i think it's crazy that i think you
should have got more money and i also
think it's crazy
she's still getting 2 million
for damages or confidence and story
damages i don't actually know what that
means
um
but i think it's great that johnny depp
is actually getting his life back and
that the truth came out and i think
on some level this does show that if you
give it time the truth does come out but
it came at the cost of this man's career
and his livelihood because
i i think that because it's a meaner
it's one thing to lose money it's
another thing to lose what you love to
do in your livelihood that is what that
man spent his career doing
he was acting that and
we also need to talk about the fact that
companies are starting to drop people
just off of allegations and
i'm all about believing credible women
but when we give a microphone and a
a platform and sympathy off the bat to
crazy women that don't deserve it like
like that's why it has to go back to
it's not the court of public opinion it
shouldn't be the court of the media it's
the court of law and what
and what evidence do you have
um because again crazy people
will abuse our natural ability to
empathize with women and are not natural
inclination to protect women
um so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments that's just my immediate
thoughts because i just got the news
that this broke
and
i know this is bad timing but
let me know what you guys think don't
forget to subscribe to the channel like
the video and i will talk to you guys
next time